what if the stabby maniac was your best
friend or your ex-wife what if it was
you these murder mysteries were all
about the killer twist and of course
we're talking spoilers for these movies
in 2021's last night in SoHo Edgar
Wright teamed up with stars Anya Taylor
joy and Thomas and Mackenzie to tell a
twisted tale of Broken Dreams and
painful paths Ellie is an aspiring
fashion student who feels she belongs to
the 1960s rather than present times
Ellie's wish appears to come true when
she gets transported in her dreams into
the past Ellie finds herself sharing a
body with Sunday an aspiring 60s singer
who's manipulated into forced sex work
after investigating Ellie believes Sandy
was murdered by her pimp and she sets
out to uncover the truth in the end it's
revealed that Sandy never died instead
she turned into a serial killer
murdering the men who abuse her and
eventually became the landlady of the
very building where Ellie lives in the
present day a girl did die up there I
suppose
the young me
the murder on the orients express stars
as director Kenneth Branagh in the lead
role as one of the most famous fictional
detectives
on board a lavish train in the middle of
nowhere while Roma's grapple with an
unexpected murder that occurs during the
journey the Federated detective takes
his time examining the motives of each
passenger on the train he discovers that
everyone aboard has a past linked to the
victim and a plausible reason for
wanting him dead so who was the killer
well it's every single passenger on the
train except for Barrow turns out that
all pulled their resources together and
killed him as a group to Alley suspicion
over any one person
in 2019's Knives Out filmmaker Ryan
Johnson gave the world a new detective
named Benoit Blanc a gentleman sleuth
played by Daniel Craig sporting an
outrageous southern accent that fateful
night seems at first glance to fill that
Hall perfectly a donut hole in a donut
hole the movie hinges on the murder of
famed novelist Harlem thrombi and the
many family members who stood to gain
from his death halfway through the movie
another twist is thrown into the
proceedings when it's revealed that
Harlan's death was a medical accident at
the hands of his nurse Mata played by
Anna De Amos but then it turns out a new
mystery person is blackmailing MATA in
connection to the murder the only point
of support for MATA is Harlan's handsome
and debonair grandson Hugh played by
Chris Evans Marta's trust turns out to
be misplaced in the end when it's
revealed that Hugh was the person who'd
been secretly blackmailing her was also
the killer of Harlan's housekeeper and
set up the medical scenario resulting in
Harlan's death the twists and turns
served up by Knives Out make it one of
the most entertaining entries in the
murder mystery genre
following the success of The Da Vinci
Code the 2009 sequel Angels and Demons
saw somehang's return as symbologist
Robert Langdon on a mission in the
Vatican the movie opens with the murder
of a reputed scientist and priest who'd
made a groundbreaking new scientific
discovery the discovery led to the
creation of a bomb with massive
destructive capabilities it falls to
Langdon and his allies to locate and
dispose of the weapon before it
detonates among the people helping
London is Father Patrick McKenna played
by Ewan McGregor the deceased the Pope's
right-hand man after coming across as a
Messianic figure throughout the movie
Langdon discovers near the end that
McKenna is responsible for the previous
Pope's death
in 2010 Martin Scorsese delivered a
mind-bending investigative Thriller with
Shutter Island set in the 1950s the
story takes place on a Lonely Island
that houses an institution for the
mentally ill two U.S Marshals Leonardo
DiCaprio's Teddy and Mark ruffalo's
Chuck arrive at the island to
investigate The Disappearance of a woman
Teddy suspects has somehow connected to
a missing patient named Andrew ladus as
Teddy draws closer to the heart of the
mystery surrounding the island and its
inhabitants he comes to realize a
shocking truth his real name is Andrew
ladies and Teddy the U.S Marshal was an
identity he'd created to cope with the
reality of having murdered his wife
after she killed their three children
during a manic episode everything that
Teddy season does throughout the movie
is his therapists attempt to let him
play out a fantasy and then return to
the real world after putting his
delusions to rest
in the movie often Kate and John Coleman
adopt a nine-year-old Russian girl named
Esther from a local orphanage the
arrangement seems to work out well for a
time until Esther starts showcasing
violent behavior and an unusual degree
of possessiveness towards John after a
series of tragic events before the
family or revolving around Esther Kate
discovers the truth of the matter as
thur as in reality a 33 year old woman
named Lena klammer who suffers from a
medical condition that stunts her
physical growth and keeps her looking
unnaturally young meanwhile as though is
plotting to get Kate and her two other
children out of the way so she can have
Jon alter herself
the invitation follows well a man still
struggling with grief after a terrible
tragedy to make things more complicated
he's attending a dinner party being
hosted by his ex-wife Eden and her new
partner David complete with friends he
hasn't seen in years things are awkward
from the get-go and a bigger wrench is
thrown into the proceedings following
the Revelation that certain members of
the party are participants of a cult
called the invitation yet later revealed
that Eden and David are acting on orders
from the cult and intend to kill the
other guests as a way to alleviate all
their pain and grief and move on to the
next plane of existence not only does
the plan work to a large extent it's
syndicated at the ends that other
members of The Cult all over the city
are carrying out similar plans on a
massive scale
a psychological horror film Secret
Window follows Johnny Depp as mystery
writer Mort Rainey whose life is
crumbling around him following a brutal
divorce trying to escape his personal
pain Mort holds himself away in a cabin
for weeks to work in peace although he
struggles to write that's when a man
named shooter arrives to confront Mort
over claims that the author plagiarized
Shooter's short story as everything
falls into place in the film's finale
it's revealed that Mort suffers from a
mental disorder and he created the
ultimate personality of shooter as a way
to cope it was always Mort's intention
acting a shooter to kill his ex-wife and
her new husband he succeeds in doing so
by the end of the film and happily goes
back to work
in Primal Fear Richard Gere plays Martin
Vale a hot shot defense attorney
obsessed with money and fame however
Vale is attracted to the case of the
murder of an Archbishop with the chief
suspect being 19 year old altar boy
Aaron stampler played by Edward Norton
the court case becomes a matter of
convincing the jury that Meek little
Aaron with his stutter and his violent
split personality of Roy was not in his
right mind when he killed the Archbishop
a man he loved and admired after a
hard-fought battle Vale wins his case
and gets Aaron acquitted using the
insanity plea in one of the most
shocking twists in cinema history Aaron
reveals the veil at the end that he'd
been acting the whole time he had in
fact been responsible for killing the
Archbishop In Cold Blood and Roy was his
true personality the whole time there
never was
and Aaron
counselor
the original saw in 2004 pretty much
became the poster child for hiding the
killer in plain sight the breakout
success of that film meant a sequel was
released only a year later and the twist
this time was well it used the same
twist in sawzu a new batch of victims
are imprisoned by jigsaw including
Amanda young a woman he'd captured once
before the group is then made to solve a
series of bloody and horrifying Escape
rooms with the premise of a painful
death that they failed to follow the
instructions or try to cheat you know
the story by now after playing the game
almost to the end detective Matthew's
son Daniel appears to be one of the last
players standing Daniel was targeted
because Matthews was a corrupt cop who's
ruined many lives by planting false
evidence this leaves the detective to
race towards Daniel's location only to
be captured and this revealed that
Amanda has become an accomplice of
jigsaws she's been working alongside the
killer the whole time and in the end she
leaves Matthews to die alone in a room
while jigsaw watches the whole thing
with satisfaction
in the film gothicar Halle Berry plays
the role of Dr Miranda gray a
psychiatrist who suffers a car crash one
night waking up in the penitentiary
where she works Miranda is shocked to
find out that she's been charged with
killing her husband although she can't
recall the events of the day he died as
Miranda travels deeper down the road to
solving the mystery of her incarceration
it's revealed that her late husband had
been a serial killer to make matters
worse Miranda also realizes at the last
moment that sheriff Bob Ryan who seemed
to be helping clear her name was
actually her late husband's accomplice
who planned to kill her off as well
the movie Scream follows Sydney Prescott
whose friends are being targeted by the
masked Ghostface Killer who likes to
make taunting phone calls to his victims
before attacking them in their most
vulnerable moment as the plot unfolds
Sydney becomes convinced that her
boyfriend Billy is the killer but
getting him jailed still doesn't stop
the killer from finding another victim
things come to a head during the third
Act of the movie when Billy's best
friends do Marker throws a party to
celebrate the early closure of their
score amid fresh murders at the party
Sydney finally learns of both Billy and
Stu took turns becoming ghost face to
avoid suspicion falling on either one of
them
one of Christopher Nolan's earlier films
Memento is one of the best thrillers in
Hollywood history the film opens with
guy Pierce's Leonard Shelby a man
suffering from enter a grade Amnesia
which means that he forgets new memories
after 15 minutes while calls the Amnesia
according to Leonard two thugs broke
into his home assaulted him and killed
his beloved wife however the cops don't
believe there were two criminals
involved in the crime so Leonard embarks
on a solo crusade to bring the second
Thug to Justice whose name Leonard
believes to be John G after finally
tracking down and killing the man he
thinks to be John G Leonard learns a
startling truth he'd already killed the
person he was after a year ago and he's
been killing different men since then to
keep up his confused Crusade come on you
got your revenge enjoy it where you
still remember
the 1960s psychological horror Thriller
classic psycho opens with a woman named
Marion crane on the run from the law in
connection with a crime looking for
shelter for the night Marion stops the
nondescript Bates Motel run by a timid
and nervy manager Norman Bates Emmanuel
resides in a house near the motel along
with his angry abusive mother that night
Marion is violently killed by a woman
thought to be Norman's mom suffering
from some sort of criminal Mania Marion
says appearance at the motel attracts
the attention of her sister Leela and
local authorities Leela conducts her own
search that yields the mummified corpse
of Norman's mother it's some revealed
that Norman had killed his mother many
years ago and developed a split
personality that prompted him to dress
up like her and kill any woman he became
attracted to
2003's Neo Noir slasher identity follows
10 random Travelers that are drawn to a
deserted Motel one night to escape a
rainstorm over the night one by one each
of the Travelers are killed off
meanwhile in a different location
Malcolm Rivers has been accused of
committing a mass murder and the only
way to get him acquitted is with the
help of a journal that may contain major
Clues regarding the truth about what
really went down amid a lot of twists
and turns it's revealed that all the
characters at the motel are split
personalities belonging to Malcolm's
fractured psyche the purpose of
Imagining the motel is a way to help
Malcolm kill off one particular
alternate personality which is a
murderous psychopath well Malcolm
succeeds in killing after personality he
thinks is the killer it's eventually
revealed that the real threat all along
had been Timmy a 10 year old personality
that had actually been responsible for
the Carnage at the hotel
[Music]